so in fact I am not actually we talking
about any design work here today at all
certainly not a mite
my work there's another piece of what
that underlay a lot of the work that I
was doing when I was at the Media Lab
and since which is I've been very
interested in questions around the
evolution of communication it started
with a course that I took as a grad
student that looked at the evolution of
communication and I started looking at
something called signalling theory which
was about how honesty and deception
co-evolved and there's I'll be talking
about a little introduction to what
signalling serias but basically it's a
way of looking at how communication
functions given how profitable it can
beat a lie and what's interesting to me
is when you look at this I think we're
actually at a very interesting
inflection point in the sort of
evolution of deception in that
technology really is making things quite
different there are some ways in which
it's making deception much harder you
know there's surveillance a lot of you
now realize that you have a whole
digital footprint that makes really
reinventing yourselves very different
than it was even a generation ago when
people could go off to college and
completely forget everything about who
they were as high school students but in
other ways technology makes deception
easier there's you know a lot of you
know since the beginning of any kind of
online forum there's been all these
complaints that people were playing
around with their identity etc the piece
of it I'm going to look at be talking
about today mostly is the rise of social
robots online software agents all kinds
of things and entities that converse
with us in ways that while we know that
at heart they are not sentient beings or
intelligent beings or loving beings give
us the impression that they are all of
these things and what does this mean in
terms of our interactions with them how
do we want to design them and what sort
of things do we think are legitimate or
non legitimate ways of doing this so we
start by talking a little bit about
signaling theory and how the deception
has evolved this is
ghazal who is doing something called
starting and it's um it's an interesting
behavior like because what this is a way
that gazelles respond to seeing some
kinds of predators that instead they're
because those are super fast but instead
of running off when they see what's
called a coursing predators like dogs
and wild dogs and other kinds of
predators that try and outrun them the
fastest gazelles the slow gazelles
actually do run off but the fast ones
just jump up and down in place and
what's interesting is the dogs don't run
after the ones that are doing that in
general and it's a form of honest
communication that says or that what the
interpretation through signaling theory
is that it's a way of saying I am so
fast that I have time to waste if I was
a slower gazelle I would really have to
run because if you happen to go after me
while I was doing this I would have to
take off running the reason that this is
better than just right you might think
well why don't they just run if they're
so fast is if running is still more
dangerous it takes up more energy than
jumping up and down like this does for
the gazelles and you're also more likely
to injure yourself like if you're a
gazelle and running very fast they're
more likely to you know hurt their leg
or have some kind of injury so this is a
safer thing but obviously if you were
slow and a dog went after you it could
pull you down so they have to be able to
still take off really fast if they need
to so ideas that this evolved is a way
of communicating honestly between
adversaries because part of it is since
there are still are occasions when the
dogs will test this a gazelle who is
being dishonest who is slow and still
tied to spring up and down like this and
some of it sometimes they do see this
where one is a little bit slower it will
get eaten so it's a way that they have
to become honest enough in their
communication another example is
something like this moose and the idea
here is that these moose grow antlers
that take up to thirty percent of all
their metabolism now one of the things
is
if you're a moose you want to be able to
communicate with other moves that might
be fighting you for territory but you
don't want to give up all your territory
or made to someone who just comes up to
you and says hi I'm stronger time to
move over because if they're not you
know you've just given up all your
territory you're made to someone who in
fact you could have be in a fight but
when they actually fight even the victor
loses because they will injure each
other so badly that they're likely to
get taken down in the next fight or
develop a horrible infection so I want
to avoid fighting but they need to have
this honest signal and so the idea here
is that these antlers have grown so
large that it's not just to be for
fighting but that admits metabolically
only the strongest ones could even hold
their head up and grow them and so it's
an honest signal that they can evaluate
each other in advance and so they don't
have to fight and so for a minute what
I'd like to do is just you define a
couple of vocabulary words that we will
be using they're very helpful when you
think about the ways that you try and
get information about someone else
around you there's all kinds of things
you use and I'll use the term cue for
anything you might use to get
information about some other being and
it could be something that was intended
for communication or could just be
anything else it could be for instance a
mosquito finds your presence by the co2
you give off now you don't intend to do
this and so we'll use the term evidence
for cues that were not meant for
communication because you didn't evolve
to tell mosquitoes you're there but you
give off co2 for other reasons that some
information that they use signals are
something that evolved or is consciously
intended for communication and that
other beings can use to pick some some
underlying quality up to understand
because so many of the things we want to
know about each other or animals want to
know about each other our hidden
qualities we can't see if someone else
is intelligent you can't see directly if
someone you want a higher stone you
can't see directly if there could be a
good employee you know professors cannot
see directly if a student
they have to you have tests or other
ways of doing it you can't see directly
if someone's in love with you you have
ways of trying to gauge that in you know
in other ways but so we have to rely on
signals and what makes it important to
make that distinction is because a
signal is something whose function
purpose is for communication if because
what happens if a signal becomes
unreliable if it's something that's very
easy to mimic dishonestly if you're the
recipient of such an unreliable signal
at some point you never know if it's
going to tell you the information you
want if a signal becomes too unreliable
it will cease to function because no one
would ever believe it anymore so
signaling has a kind of dynamic is that
as long as there's something keeping it
reliable enough it will be listened to
it will be beneficial to the signal or
because they're being believed will be
beneficial to the recipient because
they're learning something true if a
signal is very easy to cheat it ceases
over time to become used because it
becomes too harmful for the receivers
who get cheated too many times but
exactly where that balances for
different things can vary because some
things are not that harmful some signals
turn out to have other benefits that may
be pleasant to hear or listen to or
enjoyable in some other ways so a lot of
what would be looking at our how the
dynamics of this type of signaling works
you can see this sometimes in the human
world if you are trying you know if you
said wanted to signal I am very wealthy
it could be very useful to have a very
very expensive car to show off your
wealth with part of it too is that it's
you know there's all kinds of things you
could do you could also just sit down
and take you know hundred-dollar bills
and burn them but you know so I from the
entertainment value once or twice it's
not actually that enjoyable to others so
one of the things that's also useful
about something like the expensive car
is that it is something that other
people may want to pay attention to and
choose to notice one you're driving down
the street and it's a Lamborghini it's
very loud you know it could be quieter
but it's certainly designed to get your
attention it can be pleasurable to get a
ride in it
so there's other pieces that go along
with why particular designs work that
way it's Valentine's Day coming up this
weekend and so there's all kinds of
signaling for gifts part of which might
be signaling economically I am going to
give you an expensive gift it might be
signaling I understand your tastes very
well there's a economics article that
shows up every year at Christmas called
the deadweight loss of Christmas by you
know a very Scrooge like economist who
saying you know we lose billions of
dollars in the economy every year
because people give gifts that nobody
wants and so if everybody just gave gift
certificates are better yet to stop
giving gifts it would be so much better
for the economy because we wouldn't be
wasting all this money but part of that
waste in gift-giving is the cost of
being able to show off that you know
something about that other person's
taste that it's a way of saying there's
lots of complicated messages and
gift-giving but one of the things that
they miss there is a lot of that waste
is the inherent cost the risk that you
are taking in saying I'm guessing what
you want and if you don't make a mistake
being able to give something that
strongly signals I understand you and I
know what you like in so we were talking
about the evolution of communication so
those are examples of costly signals and
one of the reasons that they work is
that there's a sort of basic equation
and signaling theory which is that a
signal will be reliable if it is
affordable to be given because it's not
affordable to give and affordable I
don't just mean by money it could be in
terms of any kind of resource time
energy whatever but if it's affordable
to give by honest signalers but
prohibitively expensive for ones who
don't have a quality it's that it's
giving it will be reliable conventional
signals which are used a lot by humans
and also by many other social animals
though research in that is still very
primitive our signals where there's
nothing inherent in the form of the
signal itself that makes it honest but
there's different social things that
keep it honest enough to function so for
instance it is you can buy siren lights
on the web it's very easy they are a
conventional signal of being a policeman
you could put them on your car and I
already spent yesterday being stuck in
San Francisco traffic and you can just
make your way through traffic really
fast and usually but it turns out that
we have a lot of social sanctions in
this case you know their government
imposed sanctions and you will get fined
and sent to jail if you impersonate a
policeman so it's not that the signal is
so hard to give and that there's
something magical about being a
policeman lets you do that but society
frowns upon it and makes it too costly
so that can exist within so it's not
necessarily the form if you have social
sanctioning you can have conventional
signaling which is one of the ways
certainly human language is a form not
everything about language but the fact
that you know I can say there are 10,000
people in this room it's easy as easy
for me to say that as there are what 45
people in this room the words are
themselves conventional signals is it's
not any harder to say something that's
not true but we have social sanctions
around things where they're difficult
now in the human world in particular
there's another way in which signaling
has evolved and certainly makes thing
and has advanced certain certainly our
inventiveness quite a bit which is that
we are beyond almost any other certainly
well beyond any other animal very very
good at faking things and one of the
things if you start looking at signals
and honesty that's really amazing is how
it's almost impossible to think of a
signal that you could give as a human
being that is it valuable to give that
you know that being believed to do this
is a value that there's not some way to
fake so we've invented cubic zirconia to
go along with diamonds you know it
turned out once you know for any of you
who know the the history of Sun Tanning
the like the whole idea that wants all
the jobs we've been to the factories it
became valuable to be able to show off
that you have a tan you had
leisure to be out in the Sun and so once
tanning became something being tan said
I have high status I look really good
I've been on vacation we invented
machines to be able to give you a tan we
have spray tanners we have bronzers we
have tanning booths just an
extraordinary industry of being able to
fake the look of having gone on a
beautiful vacation without actually
enjoying the vacation but having the
look of it we have you know we value
being able to signal that you are
youthful with you know beautiful
youthful skin and we have a monthly
billion-dollar cosmetic surgery industry
to fake that we we have elocution
lessons this is the big millions of the
original Eliza giving allocution lessons
where if it's important to signal that
you were born in a different place or of
a different social class and you were
and you and to be able to signal I speak
as if I grew up in this other way so
there are just many many many ways that
we do this the other thing to keep in
mind and we're get to robots in a second
for those of you or thinking like we did
the robots go but there is that hint in
the word in this this is Eliza if the
receivers don't mind the deception and
then they don't impose any cost you can
have a system where you have quite a lot
of and part of the problem in talking
about this is that as a society we're
very against lying there are not very
many good terms for things being not
true they're not highly pejorative but
another way another piece that's
important to keep in mind is not all
lies or harmful and in fact there are a
lot of lies that are fairly important if
you in front of you who have children or
I mean all of you have been children or
around it one of the things that we do
and you have it like a two-year-old or
three year old is you have to teach them
not to tell the truth because that's
what toddlers do all the time is they
blurt out really uncomfortable things
they stare at people they shouldn't be
staring at they tell you how much they
hate you know the gift that their
grandmother just gave them every
you just found a lot of time saying no
you have to say that I guy like this no
you really can't stare at that person
and no you can't say you don't like this
you can't say you know why you know why
does your nose look so funny don't know
you know you have to pretend something
else so there's a tremendous amount of
not being truthful that is not just you
know okay but without it society simply
could not function you know if you had a
world in which everyone said the truth
all the time we would be you know at war
all the time if you think of a person
who never who always tells the truth all
the time that is someone who has a very
hard time fitting into society and so
what one of the things to remember about
signaling is it's this kind of economic
system and it goes back and forth and a
lot of it is about not saying that
deception is right or wrong but where is
the harm coming from and there's two key
places one is that the receiver may be
harmed by being deceived but there's
also harm that can come to the giver of
an honest signal when that signal
becomes overrun by dishonest signalers
but in the absence of harm there you can
have a lot of things where deceptions
either required or certainly we can go
along with quite a bit of unreliability
so now we will move back into the world
of robotics one of the things that was
interesting to me when I was looking at
robots I think most of you are probably
familiar with the Turing test but when
you think about it so just a quick
review so this is Turing's paper from
1950 that was published in a philosophy
journal and in this he wrote that he was
the first going to address the question
of can machine think and then he
immediately says without question is
just completely meaningless we can never
figure that out we don't we don't really
have a definition of what it means to
think so instead where he's going to
consider the substituting for that
question the idea of an imitation game
it's this parlor game he says you know
there's this game you have someone
behind a curtain they sent messages
written back and forth and the idea is
you know they everyone they're all
claimed their women but we
no if it's a man or a woman you try and
figure out by the way they answer
questions is this really woman or
someone pretending to be a woman let's
substitute a machine it'll type the text
back and forth yesterday man this in
1950 there's no you know there are
actually machines yet that did this but
it will send the messages back and forth
and if once the machine can fool us into
thinking it's human we'll have to think
of it as thinking and he predicted that
this would happen by in 50 years which
would be the year 2000 2000 came and
went we didn't quite have it but we're
getting very close to this today now
there's a lot of really interesting
things about this paper one is that is
the whole question of whether this is a
useful substitution for the idea of
kanna machine think for the purposes of
this talk the piece I'm really
interested in is that an entire kind of
branch of AI has been from the beginning
based on the problem of can we deceive
people into thinking that this computer
is a human being and what does it mean
to do that we'll talk a little bit later
about Eliza for those of you who know it
yes you know there were very early
responses that said well we could kind
of fake this fairly easily how well
computers can do with this is actually a
fairly ambiguous problem there's a
yearly test contest that's run it's not
the most respectable contest to um but
there's a very funny piece Marvin Minsky
who passed away a couple of weeks ago
tried to get Loebner to take this prize
down if you go to the page of the
Loebner prize which is a basically
Turing test competition every year it
says co-sponsored by marvin minsky
because he had said that he would pay a
hundred dollars to anyone who could get
Logan her to quit doing that lavona
wrote back and said well I'm gonna quit
doing this once someone wins the prize
and so that would satisfy Marvin's
requirement so Marvin is going to pay a
hundred dollars and now he's a
co-sponsor my prize but that aside
so this is so it's this but what's
interesting about this it's a test
that's done over a year and they have a
bunch of judges and people come up with
their chat box and they try and convince
the judges that they're human there's
actual humans that are also trying to be
human and talk with the judges so far no
one has won even this fairly limited
version I don't remember it's like a 20
minute test or something but each year
one thing does a little better it was
actually interesting as well none has
been unanimously fooled all the judges
every year some of them fools some of
the judges some of the time and the
other part is the judges are not always
good at noticing who is human so a lot
of times they've judged humans to be
computers so while this notion of so
even in a place where people are trying
very hard to think is this a human or a
computer in a limited spot the idea of
language as a signal of being human is
highly problematic so now you see where
something like this kind of fits in into
the signaling system is one of the other
pieces that's important in thinking
about sort of the economics of honesty
is that there's a cost to evaluating the
quality you're trying to assess and it's
instantly clear it's called the it's the
assessment cost basically and so here
they're saying we're going to give you
15 minutes of your time and you think
about it but in normal everyday
interactions we don't always have that
time if it's not that important for you
to know whether you're dealing with a
human or a machine or not you might not
want to sit there and interview it for
15 minutes trying to get that question
that's going to fool you into thinking
it so part of it is many things like
this if you had enough time you have
infinite resources you can invest them
into making those distinctions but if
you don't care or or you have very
little time you may have to make that
trade-off that says I can't afford that
assessment I can't afford to be fooled
so I'm just going to let this issue go
and so in real life a lot of what we are
dealing with now is being on the human
side remember I said there were two
groups that kind of lose out when a
signal becomes somewhat deceptive and
one of the groups is the honest signaler
and so one of the things that you're
used to when you see a captcha is
essentially you are paying the cost of
having to signal you are human now 30
years ago nobody SAT there and thought
wow I'm going to have to like prove
continuously that I am a human being in
order to read a newspaper but that's
sort of what we're left at today because
of the ubiquity of machine of machines
or in this case spam bots that pretend
to be human and it's interesting that
the first really ambiguously human bot
was something called the zuma by back in
usenet and this came out in like
nineteen ninety-four so usenet was sort
of the big the first big online
conversational space and people talked
about all these different topics and all
of a sudden that there started to be and
some of it was argumentative but it was
all humans and it was a very very robust
lively conversational space and there
started to be these rants that were
denying that there had ever been in
Armenian Genocide but they would turn up
in groups that we're talking about
Turkey their turnout groups that were
talking about Armenia and a first
someone thought it was just some really
obnoxious person doing this though they
were doing it quite a bit then someone
noticed that we was responding to
anything that referred to Turkey like we
had turkey for Thanksgiving anywhere on
Usenet suddenly there'd be this rant
about the Armenian Genocide coming after
it people saying this is a robot nobody
had seen this kind of bot actually
before but the problem that it
engendered was the ones you had
something like this very quickly started
to realize that anytime people got into
some kind of discussion and somebody
wanted to accuse someone of not thinking
they'd say you're a bot we know that
you're a bot and trying to get other
people to think they weren't real
and so you could see this changing that
tenor of the communication once suddenly
the idea that the person you're talking
with might not be a human being became
an actual real possibility and so all
the ones we've been talking about so far
have been text things where the issue is
saying are you actually human but now
we're removing it so and that's
certainly a growing phenomenon but now
we're sort of moving into this other
world of the cute robots now hear no one
is saying that they are going to be
mistaken for human being you know even
in Turing's paper in 1950 the reason he
gave for framing it as this imitation
game in this parlor game was you know
there was he said it's not going to
happen in any foreseeable future that
we're going to be able to build robots
that are going to physically make you
mistake them for a human being but you
know we'll see what you know synthetic
biology does with that but for the
moment we say that the physical issues
are not so much the question of whether
the thing you are dealing with is human
but partly whether it whether it whether
it is sentient whether it cares about
you in some way and a lot of things are
a lot more ineffable and hard to put our
hands on then this question of you know
is a texting human or not and so one of
the questions is not just is it sentient
but when do we care there's a lot of big
questions here that aren't just can we
judge what is sentient but also you know
in this round we can see what the signal
is it's you know it's cute it has these
big eyes but the question is what is it
that we're trying to care about with
these different features so one of the
things that's fairly ubiquitous in a lot
of these robots is they're adorable and
you know if you look at this it has
these big eyes as a little chin it has a
big forehead it looks like a baby and
there's a there's a very interesting
work that was done by a woman named
Leslie zebra wits she writes about the
bay
babyface overgeneralization problem and
the issue here is that it's very very
important for us to think to treat
things that look like babies well
because if we don't treat babe actual
babies well we will not I mean right now
the human populace not really dealing
with a under population problem but we
evolved in a state where that was a
problem and so if you think about a baby
a baby is not an inherently Pleasant
being they cry they spit up on you they
pee like they're just like they're not
very pleasant so if we had not evolved
to look at like little baby faces and
just like oh my god cute it just threw a
punk it's so adorable yeah you just say
you know why don't we just leave you
under a rock over there so our response
to baby faces and things that are
babyish is is very very very strong and
and so part of its a lot of designers
have noticed this and so the baby so the
thing is we respond to babies we cut
them a lot of slack we have very low
expectations for their intelligence but
we want to take care of them we we tend
to ascribe fairly innocent motives to
them etc and so when things have that
look one of things that Leslie zebra
wits in her research isn't talking about
robots I mean her work is very
interesting cuz she's talking about how
we see other people because this also
goes through to adults that it turns out
that you know some of us happen to have
little Chin's or big eyes or big
foreheads or very round faces some
people as adults end up looking more
like babies for reasons have nothing to
do with their personality whatsoever and
some look more the opposite of that and
it turns out that the people who look
the least like babies for instance are
seen as much more authoritative and more
intelligent on the other hand if they're
in trial they are much more likely to be
found guilty under the same
circumstances so in court you're at a
disadvantage if you don't look like a
baby but if you're actually trying to
get a job or promotion you may be at a
great disadvantage just because of the
structure of your face and so you know
obviously this is something that lets
lots of designers have had you know we
can sell cars with this etc so the
commercial world is full of things that
look like babies but so and then we we
have things like we have a lot of toys
and they elicit a lot of warmth I mean
if you look at this beer now think about
like abandoning this beer somewhere like
if this was your beer you would feel
like you take care of it you might you
say goodbye to it when you put it on a
shelf it's very easy for us even without
adding in any element of robotics or
intelligence or anything for us to think
about objects that have this kind of
cuteness to them as sentient sort of
beings with feelings and elicits that
sort of caretaking from us so one of the
questions though is what happens when
it's even more interactive now one of
the things you might notice here is that
this is a smart beard oh you're not
getting to see this because it's shown
to it but if this only has two stars by
the way so some of them may be more
successful than others we are having
this talk because we're at the cusp of
these things being successful but right
now a lot of them are sitting there in
that uncanny valley where they act a
little sentient life but just enough to
be really irritating it turns out but
but here where was you have toys like
this where the interaction comes from
this from that being a child who's
playing with a stuffed bear really knows
that when that beer talks back to them
that at some level they have made up
that interaction but now you have toy
beers that look really cute but they
actually respond to you so the idea that
this is another being outside of your
having given it imaginary sentence is
much stronger so one of the questions
for instance we won't want to be
thinking about here is you know here's
that other kind of honest signal or you
know the pet guinea pig but now all of a
sudden how does like for instance one of
the questions these these are questions
we don't know the answers to yet but how
does it change if you grow up in a world
where
your pet toys talk to you ask you about
your day they remember your their
interactions with you etc and very
friendly they know your name and
everything does it make something like
your guinea pig seem dumber and duller
and less interesting because it doesn't
know your name and it doesn't really
care that you came from home from school
you know so is this sort of changing our
model of how we deal with things sort of
the interactions with other non-human
things and changing our expectations in
some kind of subconscious way just one
other note about this neonate this
neoteny which is the term for things
that tend to look kind of babyish these
are foxes it's a little hard to see in
here because it's light but these are
foxes from a really interesting
experiment that was done in Russia over
about a 50 year period where the actual
thing was to actually prove some other
genetics point because it was the Russia
of non non-mendelian genetics but what
the experimenters were doing was they
took a bunch of foxes and they kept
bleeding from every generation just the
friendliest ones they weren't trying to
breed ones that looked more childlike
they had a set of very strict protocols
they used about like how does it
approached you how does it feed how how
high it is they were looking for ones
that did not express anger and ones that
seemed a little fearful of humans and
they just kept reading them Brina they
do like many generations of it and it's
apparently they're still breeding them
but they ended up with was not only very
friendly foxes who wag their tails of
all kinds of very doglike behaviors but
what they didn't expect was their faces
got shorter their chins got smaller
their eyes got bigger so a whole number
of other neoteny straights went along
with friendliness so there's some it
turns out there's a lot of very
interesting cross genetics about it but
just now we'll go back to looking at
fake cute jnanis animals so this is pero
who is a
interactive very cute seal and he's made
in Japan he's about sixteen hundred
dollars so how he responds he's very
responsive people like it very much so
one of the things to think about in how
we judge because here they start to be
things that are unless you kind of know
what's going on inside very hard for you
to make the sense that this is a machine
that you're dealing with as opposed to
some kind of sort of sentient responsive
being now the framework that they use
pero in is nursing homes where they say
it turns out that dementia patients we
spawned really well to having animals
with them and it calms them down etc but
dementia patients aren't really good at
taking care of animals so you don't
actually want it's not actually kind to
an animal let alone to the patient to
leave them there but you can give them
this artificial seal and it will / and
it will ma go up to them and it will
sort of murmur little seal nothings at
them and it will come patients down who
are really agitated so it seems here
that you know the idea of having
something like this these are to mention
patients there you know you're basically
in a palliative care situation it seems
like it's a benefit but when we start
thinking about replacing an actual pet
with these for say children it seems a
little like a somewhat different
equation that we're making of saying
here you're going to lavish your
affection on this pet this is this is
not my words this is the words of the
the site neco venus uses the latest and
sense of robotic technology to create a
truly interactive pet the reacts tears
stimuli when you pet it including
realistic meowing blah blah blah blah
blah she even raises her paw in a way
that only a cat does so yeah this is you
know it's this is something that do you
feel you know one of the things i think
it was like do you feel that this is a
adequate substitution for a pet what is
it you know what it makes us question
what is it that we are doing with pets I
mean there is a kind of funny phenomenon
that humans have pets you sort of think
so it does you know if he's trying to
think I'm not going to even answer here
about what I rather the ethics or
desirability of this but it does make us
it gives us another framework for
thinking about what is it about these
relationships with these other beings
that that's desirable so here's you know
here's the real a cat so but you also
see now than the Antony and you know
this is an actual cat in an actual cat's
face but part of the piece that's also
interesting with it is for me is when
you are lavishing affection on a
artificial animal so you know they've
looked at things like how those
particularly the dementia patients what
is it that makes it so nice to hold this
animal oxy there's a couple of things
but sort of the simplest of neuroscience
side of it is that oxytocin is the sort
of called the love hormone but it's one
of the hormones that gives us sort of
the Kickstarter that humans need to
cooperate and a lot of you know if
you're familiar with love game theory
there's the problem of how do you get
people to cooperate in the beginning you
sort of need this like sort of extra
oomph to get it to work and it turns out
that hormonal e there's a lot of ways
that cooperating brings us pleasure and
it turns out that being around a pet is
a very pleasurable experience it's sort
of you know you don't usually most of us
don't actually need a neuroscientist to
tell you that but it also turns out that
it has the same effect on the animal
particularly the study study show that
it really has a big effect on dogs that
being petted and loved is really really
releases a lot of oxytocin and dogs less
on cats with the important caveat that's
my cat my daughter my cat with the
important caveat that when they were
testing the cats cats are very
territorial animals and they were
testing them in a lab and so you can
bring your dog into a lab and he's just
like your wagons tail be like oh you
took me on an outing you bring a cat
into a lab and it's complete
we freaked out so the fact that they
responded at all is probably a sign that
you know if you tested them at home
where they're in charge they would have
done much better but the important point
here is that one of the questions that
brings up is how much in our
relationships do we care about the
experience of the other because if you
say well I can hold this fake pet and
love it and it makes me feel good it's
about saying I'm interested only in the
form of the signal that is sort of
loving me back I don't really care
whether there is love back to be had
whereas in the case of a relationship
with an actual animal there is at least
in some cases the fact that when you are
sitting here and petting it and
everything it's not just that it's
purring and it makes you feel better
it's you know doing whatever dogs do I
mean you feel better it you actually are
making another being happy and so what
is you know that's the piece that the
robotic animal kind of leaves out and so
part of it is it brings up interesting
questions about how do we see all kinds
of relationships like that you know we
live in a world where a lot of our
interactions are within a service
economy so I know a lot of you are doing
your research in different types of
economic models for different for
different forms of sort of uber like
services etc and once we start thinking
about what does this remark the
marketplace for labor an enormous amount
of the labor that goes on frigiliana
service economy is a labor of saying i
am going to act as if I like you very
much you know you are going to go into
this restaurant and people love being
told oh yes that was a really really
good choice oh it's so good to see you
here again now we are we are paying
people to do this to make us feel good
those of us who have worked as
waitresses know some of the time you
think that someone time you think I hope
they give me a tip this is the sort of
table that never does I'm going to be
really pleasant but they better tip me
since it's not quite the relationship
we're seeing at some level we're aware
of this so part of the signaling
question as we're thinking about robots
is how much do we want to be fooled
in you know in general and it raises
interesting questions not just about the
robotic world but I think it also makes
us rethink our relationship with a lot
of sort of animals around us and how we
think about people and how do we want to
be thinking about them and whether you
know this is something we want to sort
of reframe or we think how we deal with
this and it happens that even so really
even met my new levels of how we think
about language there was a this is from
a there was a headline I don't know if
you could see this the couch okay you
can't really read that but this is from
a headline from The New York Times last
week is that a cow escaped from a hell
up from a slaughterer and ran through
streets of Queens before it was captured
again and the new york times ran a
headline saying the cow you know who
escaped from the slaughterhouse blah
blah blah blah blah and then they got a
letter from Peter Singer the animal
rights activist saying this is really
great we're really really happy that you
used who to refer to a cow instead of
that and it turned out that the New York
Times has a whole guidelines if they're
ap guideline is to call an animal it not
he or she unless it's X has been
mentioned or it has been personalized
with a name the dog was lost it held
mama dog Duke was lost he held and so
even at the simple level of grammar and
very little things in terms of how we
refer to another we make these
distinctions between things that we
think about as a thing because you think
about the cow because it turns out the
first thing that happened just how was
it was returned to the slaughterhouse
and there's a big difference in how the
sentence sounds that like the cow that
escaped it was sent to the
slaughterhouse versus it turns out the
cow wasn't even a cow it was a he so
they had a lot of little mistakes here
but we called as she for this exam so
but the cow who escaped she was sent to
the slaughterhouse that sounds really
cruel so even at the level
of pronouns how we think about these
others has a huge impact on what our
ethical senses about how they can be
treated this is sort of a very early
example of a so there anyone does not
know what this is okay great so it's
Tamagotchi you know it was the keychain
pet the American version was made nice
to be four you know American
sensitivities you know this is a pet you
were supposed to feed it you know click
on it defeated clean it clean it you
know do all these little things for it
the Japanese version was a little
harsher if it died it died your
Tamagotchi was dead the American one
would come back to life after you know
ten minutes or something but the point
that I wanted to make here was that how
we frame it think about taking it think
about a kid who has a tamagotchi and now
you are at your aunt's house for dinner
and you know every few minutes you get
off to go tend here just Tamagotchi if
you think about this as a computer game
you're being really rude there's all
these other people around you and you're
being rude you keep leaving the table
because you have this game that you have
to play and you're like privileges this
like little keychain object over actual
people and that says like really bad
things about like what technology is
doing to our relationship with humans on
the other hand if you think about this
as okay it's a pet where you think we
know it's not really a pet but this is a
child and sort of a training pet then
not leaving the table and letting the
pet died seems kind of creepy like you
don't really want to let your child have
this training pet and then tell it like
oh well if there's something else you
should be doing it doesn't really matter
that it didn't didn't get fed and died
that seems like kind of a weird way to
raise a child like of course your child
should be leaving the table to do this
so these framings are really important
in terms of the sort of the lessons that
we think about with these things and so
now we're going to go back to the 1960s
again and Eliza not the Pygmalion Eliza
but the sort of computer program Eliza
and Eliza was a professor named Joseph
wizened
response to Turing's paper on using
language and he to tell him you know if
your if a machine is intelligent and he
wrote a program and it used a very very
simple parser and this is a 1965 and you
can still find this running there's
millions of versions of it on the web it
was a very simple parser and it
basically spat back your sentences to it
and this is actually this is um in an
actual interaction with Eliza that I did
and one of the but the thing is he
framed it as saying it's a Rogerian
psychologist and they did was it's a
psychologist who basically whatever you
say is going to say well why did you say
that what makes you think this and so it
was a framing they made it you know this
kind of simple sentences makes sense and
so what wisin bombs intention in making
Eliza was he wanted to show that
language was not a good proxy for being
a smart machine that it was going to be
very easy to build interactions that
would fool people into thinking someone
was human like that it didn't mean that
it was in any way intelligent that it
just showed that the ability to carry on
a conversation with text was just not a
good proxy for that question whatsoever
what happened was people just love this
program and his secretary apparently
said I would like you to leave the room
I am talking to this in private they
really liked the idea of it being a
therapist people wrote articles saying
this is the future of psychotherapy
wisin bob was so horrified by this that
he basically left the field of computer
science and spent the rest of his career
warning about the dehumanizing
possibilities of machines and in
particular how dehumanizing it was that
we were willing to have this type of
relationship with a machine so one piece
of it was you know is that you know what
is it in the relationship to a therapist
is it better to have something like this
machine that will just sort of ask you
questions back what is it that having a
real human being at the other end of a
therapeutic relationship bring
you is it sort of like the waitress
where you're paying someone to have a
relationship with you what if the
therapist is actually sitting there
thinking oh guys okay this is my most
tedious patient yes dear yes what why
why did you do that would you rather be
talking to machine that might not be
thinking things about you but just being
too well trained not to let you know so
part of it is because of these questions
and they're still there actually quite
real today this is um some contemporary
research not sure if this is actually at
Stanford it may be a Stanford project
elsewhere or came from a student who
went off and became a professor
somewhere else but this is doing a robo
therapist interface for the Veterans
Administration with ideas they said well
we have so many people who need therapy
and you know we don't have enough
therapist we're really going to do you
know we're going to do machine based
therapy it's very useful and so part of
so part of the questions here is you
know is this you know is this a good
future to be building is this a useful
way of doing therapy if a machine is
says the exact same things that a human
being would say in response is there any
different from this you know is this a
case or what are the cases where what we
really care about is the internal
experience of the person or animal or
thing that we are relating to or the
existence even of an internal experience
and when do we just care about the words
or the meowing or the purring or
whatever that we are getting back from
them and we're at you know as human
beings we really really care about other
what others think of us so that
experience of what is going on in the
minds of others is something that is
really important to us if we buy a lot
of self-help books trying to help us
make a better impression on others and
so you know I think what a lot of what
wisin bomb was worried about was our you
know is the increasing
common at common asst of things that
come to us with the impression that they
are thinking about us and caring about
us in ways that it's very hard for a
human being to do because for instance a
machine can be infinitely patient a
machine can remember an infinite number
of details about you in a way that your
actual friends cannot do does this start
to change how we deal with other human
beings in reality the other side too is
you know a more benign version of the
why did the secretary send wise a mom
out of the room but maybe it wasn't
maybe she wasn't really relating it to
it as a quasi human being at all maybe
it was just like a quiz maybe it was
just sort of that type of interface or
an interaction or like the way we might
say you know dear diary and sort of
confess all kinds of things to some kind
of inaccurate not an inanimate object
and so speaking of Diaries though I
think this brings up one other issue
that's important to keep in mind about
interactions with the machine
intelligence is this a great quote from
the Harry Potter books this is um the
diary that Ginny confided in but it
turned out that it's brain that it
behind it was being controlled by
Voldemort and Ginny said mr. Weasley
Fabregas did haven't I taught you
anything what have I always told you
never trust anything that can think for
itself if you can't see where it keeps
its brain and so now we have Barbie
where you have a Barbie that you give to
a child and it can think and it can seem
like it's thinking it can talk it can
interact and but you're its brain is in
the cloud or you know in Mattel it is a
wirelessly connected dolls for sale now
it's wirelessly connected it records
what your child is saying and ships that
information up to Mattel which sends it
back information about how best to
respond to it and so part of this is you
get a highly interactive dalts not
always clear here you don't extent that
this is entirely machine-based that mean
to do so part of it is it's learning how
to be more machine based
of it maybe there's humans doing this
but it's also the whole side of what
goes on with that information you are
interacting with someone whose brain you
cannot see but you feel is sort of the
simple innocent all sitting here it
could be you know that all of the
interactions go off to perhaps a
marketing department what happens if it
over here is you know over here is
something what if it over here's the
parents talking about something illegal
or whatever there's all kinds of pieces
like that about thinking here it's where
does the thing that you are speaking
with keep its mind there have been other
sort of recent issues I don't know how
many of you know that Ashley Madison
scandal from it's like a year ago
slashing Madison for those who don't
know it was a dating site that was sort
of this notorious site because it would
build itself as the dating site for
married people who wanted to have
affairs and and one of the things that
was really interesting about it was that
they were like there are a lot of men on
the site but they're also lots and lots
of women it was kind of surprising his
people don't think they're that many
women would go to a site legs if it
turns out there were tons of them then
Ashley Madison got hacked and so at
first people thought the big Ashley
Madison scandal was going to be it had
all of these guys names and that they
were on the site for cheating on your
wife but then it also turned out once
again the hackers just released the full
database of all the users of this site
turned out like the men were real but
the women were not that like there were
almost no actual women on the site they
were almost all bots and so all these
men had been paying and it was a fairly
expensive site but in paying and paying
but what they had been interacting with
were fake human beings so that brings up
one other piece of it is that in from
the singling so I remember we said that
there's though of this expense of being
fooled and there's also the receiver
assessment costs but one of the
questions here too is how motivated are
you to make that assessment so here in
some ways we have
a set of people who might have been
fairly motivated to be deceived and
that's you know one other piece here is
and that's another piece with the
cuteness and the disarming pneus is as
the recipient of of that kind of
affection whether it's you know Ashley
Madison were very cute robot how much
does the experience of it make you into
a kind of willing receiver of something
that's not actually true and then just
one final designed he said you had a
question um so I had heard about that
but were they actually BOTS or did they
pay people to kind of back tangible
right back they were both in
programmatic and then I think there were
a huge number of them and they had I
mean if they weren't you know strictly
speaking they weren't sort of all
individual software agents I think there
were a series of scripts were they
scraped images from both a few people
who had submitted there but just from
all over the web and built up these
profiles and then they just had a lot of
scripted interactions this american life
story recently where there was these
people who pay all this money to
subscribe to us and to be pen pals with
these women and it was just a small it
was actually a guy who wrote most the
letters and even any way to jail for a
long time for fraud and it was kind of
similar setup yeah except with no plots
yeah so yeah basically bots are putting
out of work all the people who were
doing fraudulent human things like that
so so it James had mentioned earlier
that he was at a economics talk the
other night that I think Kelly opened
with this slide of a broad book Brooks
with Baxter but it's just one last sort
of cute robot in one last point I wanted
to leave with here just in particular
from a design perspective to because um
so this one is interesting because one
of the things that rod Brooks has talked
about with the design of Baxter also a
cute face robot but here the kunis is
the
and everything are not simply to be
disarmingly cute but they're meant to be
highly functional it's there used to be
an interface design of society eyes as
output it's the use of gays to show
where am I looking and so part of the
idea here is that you this is a robot
that's going to be very very easily
trained for doing lightweight tasks
whether they are in a factory floor or
ultimately in your home and part of it
is how do you have a fairly intuitive
interaction with this and that if you
can see the eyes you know it could you
know you could say you know use this
thing and you can see that you can do
things like refer to this because you
have a very intuitive way of knowing
where its attention is and things like
that and so what I wanted just as a sort
of provocation so a lot of what I've
been saying is well here are these
pieces that are sort of fooling you into
thinking that there are other things one
of the scenarios that he's talked about
for Baxter is for things like elder care
you know if you you know if you are
bedridden and you need to be turned
every day or you need to be changed and
bathed you can have a robot do this and
here it's sort of this interesting
question about care also because there
comes the question for instance of
dignity of where people say you know I
find that the idea of being cared for in
that sense really humiliating you know I
don't want people to see me in this
state whereas if the thing that is
taking care of you doesn't actually have
any feelings because it's not actually
sent here is this something that would
maintain more dignity but in that case
do you want it to look less like a human
to remind you more that it's a machine
and so part of it is there's the issues
of deception there's the issues of
self-deception but there's also the
questions of when is it that we want to
be dealing with an interface and not and
so you know obviously here I think one
of the undercurrents here is like a lot
of work that comes you know from
Stanford in the immediate equation work
that people always deal with machines is
some kind of human being but we you know
we deal with chairs we do
with almost every object we have the
potential to deal with as a animate
thing but lease Brel and her colleagues
did some work again maybe you know so
many years ago where they looked at how
honest people were in filling out forms
they were like sort of these pseudo
employment forms they would ask things
like you know dude you ever shop Leo did
you ever steal a pencil from office
supplies but they tested it with two
machines to computers so I saw I had one
had a face and one didn't and what they
found where people were much more honest
when they were answering questions to
text than they were to computers with
faces and their hypothesis was that we
deal with other human beings in a social
way and that remember we talked about
how much we really want others or really
anything that we think of in that sort
of human large sphere of the human
context to think well of us and so for
instance react more nicely towards
things that we think of you know that
was one of the media equation pieces you
if you're if you're critiquing a program
you'll be nicer to it on the computer
that about it on the computer in which
you ran it but here was also you will
you will try and make a better
impression on a machine that has a face
whereas you're more likely to be open
and honest with a machine that reads to
you clearly as being a machine and so
the questions of honesty and deception
here I think our come across in many
many different realms of it and from the
designer perspective in particular
there's both ethical issues but there's
also practicality issues I think the
signaling framing is a really useful one
for forcing you in particular not only
to understand sort of the balance
between you know where where do you want
the signal itself where do you care
about the underlying quality but also
forcing us to think about what actually
are the qualities we want to know about
the other thank you
no I'll make one one comment I remember
back when I back in my AI days 40 years
ago um becoming aware of the human
superhuman fallacy and I think what that
issue referred to was that well many
eyes he eyes are down here and the
here's our way up here they're super
humid they're all wise all understanding
whereas you know our fellow humans this
isn't a point you directly address but
but our fellow humans are I mean are
clearly flawed our psychologists are not
what Watson bomb would seek in a
psychotherapist a lot of them are
trouble themselves our presidential
candidates are troubled and have
difficulties so maybe we should be
running a robot for president well yeah
thank you much so so there you go well
so we're a long ways yeah yeah I had it
I wonder if you could talk a little bit
to the kind of the ethical
considerations as we think about these
systems and whether or not these signals
choo choo or does a designer have more
ethical responsibility when they're
tapping into signals they are sort of
part of our evolution part of our you
know our cognitive processes that were
unaware of what you talked about you
know the shape of the face and whatnot
versus sort of these social signals that
we've developed you know through our
culture and and is there a difference
there or do you just see this as a need
for us to consider these the same way um
well I think the ones is that your
prints like that the facial bones are
harder for us to adjust around because
we're very very very deep-seated so I
think you could say that there may be a
greater ethical issue there because our
ability to kind of adjust how we read
them a is very small and B if it isn't
we probably don't really want to do that
you know like you know it's like if
you're surrounded by really really cute
robots you know is a baby girl look like
a robot because the thing that you
normally see with a face like that is a
robot yeah um I think it's and I think
one of the pieces though that's also
very hard in general with talking about
any of the ethical issues is we can
frame what the ethics are but what I
think we generally see is there will
always be someone who's willing to
exploit it so it will be exploited part
of the part of the issue is how do you
make it so that people understand this
better I think the other part is to how
how to get people to be more aware of
the ways in which they're being subtly
manipulated so I'm hoping it's a good
one thing that so there's a lot I agree
with it one thing good I'd like to pick
out and trying to satify you is he sent
to which robots can signal on a
particular sort of about how we look
where we look at the agency of this if
you take the example of like uh I'll get
an airline at a an airport your check-in
counter it used to be that it would
always meet a person face to face when
you were checking in and like that at
some sense then got swapped out for the
kiosks writing this is sort of that that
same dynamic occurred and the reason why
I think you know executives still like
to talk to people because they
can't is it's not because the robot
itself of kiosk is like incapable of
signaling it somehow that it's like
United or someone had is the thing doing
the signaling if you really threw the
choice to use a person man versus a
kiosk so I'm jabot I'm trying to stroke
I am struggling to figure out what I
think here about whether it's possible
for a robot that signal for example if
there are no costs to it right all like
it's essentially free right into to do
anything ok so there's a lot of pieces
of one of them one of them is way if you
start looking at these issues around
signaling more closely as you realize
that one the experience of the receiver
is quite subjective and can be very
different than the intent of the signal
ER so on the one hand in terms of how
you respond or your willingness to keep
listening to something is all about your
subjective experience and what your
model is that what you think is
happening from the other side you know I
think one you're correct one of the ways
also in that we fool ourselves about
machine sentience is in a scribe using
verbs you know the machine was thinking
the machine was signaling you know that
are an issue of agency so to some extent
even using those words to say the
machine signals is a way of fooling
ourselves into giving it more sentience
so though it's awkward to say United was
signaling through the sort of thing but
the issue of cost is that a similar can
certainly be low cost so so the most
successful signal could be something
that's and there's a whole set of
signals called index signals that the
issue isn't whether it's costly to be
given its is it prohibitively costly to
give it deceptively and what you're here
you're seeing here is that if you're
trying to sprint some signal I'm
signaling that you are a very valued
customer it's very easy for the robot to
do that
it knows everything about you the fact
that its low cost doesn't make it a
signal it just makes it very easy for it
to do it so the cost is really about
keeping those balances but it doesn't
make it more or less of a signal I think
I'm understanding what you're saying if
I'm if computation like one of the
things that does it scales way right
then the cost of doing something
deceptively essentially goes to zero we
can I do it for you that I can do it for
anything and it's Maeby's your thesis at
some level that this this will cause
some sort of unusual social dynamics as
this unrolled yes I see right so that I
so I am working on a book on these
topics and so that's the thesis of it is
that computationally we are at a
inflection point in the kind of
economics of honesty and that part of it
is we can look at how deception has
evolved you know from costly signals and
animal signaling through humans and our
inventiveness and everything but with
computation we really are seeing some
fairly large disruption coming and in
communication both because of machines
being able to communicate with us see
the speed of our communication through
the level of surveillance it's not all
in the same direction but it's certainly
having a huge effect on what it means to
communicate okay so the problem with
mental health is that sometimes you
don't really wanna see those skills and
other people like your sample when
somebody tells you that you're stressed
you get more stressful there's no way to
thank you so sometimes you actually have
to remove those signals and machines
have been actually very helpful there's
a robotic cbt that's actually being even
like reimbursed by the UK
maria and the adoption is actually
higher and retention Sally fire not much
fired ok it's because they remove the
signals of human watching knowing are
you and being kind of like on descendant
and totally as posting that your stress
and something I you don't really wanna
know because you are ready bit stressed
and unstressed see more so sometimes
you're moving those signals alright well
quite careful because you break the
barrier that actually right yeah that's
sort of similar to the point I was
making at the end who are so like you
know what if you feel like this is a
situation that is very like a great and
dignity to be changed or cared for like
having a machine do it might actually be
better for you and so I think that
that's part of it it's not something
where you know I'm not coming here to
say like robots are really bad this is
really bad for us but I think a lot of
these are very nuanced points and
understanding because I think you we
also don't want to say Oh any time that
you enjoy it or you like it is good
because sometimes you may be paying a
big cost in terms being to see that
we're not really aware of but there may
be times here where what you're saying
is the there the experience of being in
some kind of relationship with another
human being is the problem and getting
rid of the relationship part is exactly
what you want so yes but it's probably
not the case that you want a machine
then that's pretending to be a person
but you're probably wanting there's is
some kind of interactive feedback it's
really more like a intellectual mirror
than another model than another sentient
being model alright let's see
you